BETTER?
WE LOVED HIM IN INDIANAPOLIS.
WE TALKED ABOUT T. JUST BECAUSE
SO DIFFERENT.
SO MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE.
ANOTHER PASS.
OH! TELL YOU WHAT.
THAT ANKLE FEELS BETTER.
>> HE NEEDED A FEW GAMES TO BE
OFF OF IT.
>> THIS HAPPENED SO FAST, WE
DIDN'T EVEN CATCH THE CULPRIT.
HE GOT  DRIVES AND
FINISHES.
STEVENS THE COACH, THE SCOUTING
REPORT ON STEVENS THE PLAYER, I
WAS AN  THE PASS.
>> Jeff: JUST BACKING IN, THEY
DECIDE NOT TO DOUBLE.
GOOD POST DEFENSE BY THOMPSON,
GOOD CONTEST, AND BETTER SHOT
AND ZACHUGH THE TRAFFIC . ALL T
WAY TO THE RIM  AND A LITTLE
TOO STRONG.LAURI MARKKANEN  GOT
A THREE IN AND OUT.
>> Adam: IN TORONTO THE GOT OUT
OF TRANSITION.
>> Adam: LAURI MARKKANEN EIGHT
HAS IT, AND DO YOU HAVE YOUR
TICKET?
HE THREW IT UP THERE, BABY.
GO GET IT.
WATCH THIS, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
WATCH THIS.
HE GOES TO THE RIM, FLY, YOUNG
MAN, FLY.
>> Adam: PERFECT PASS, E TO EXE
GET STOPS.
>> Ryan: HARRIS GIVES IT BACK TO
EMBIID.
GOES BEHIND THE BACK, SETS UP
THE ONE-ON-ONE WITH CARTER.
NOW NEEDS MORE BODIES.
CARTER COMES UP WITH A
>> Ryan: LaVINE LEAVES IT SHORT.
GOT IT BACK.
LaVINE, KNOCKED OUT OF BOUNDS,
EMBIID AND HARRIS THERE.
NINE TO SHOOT FOR CHICAGO.
>> Richard: HE STARTS KEYING IT
UP.
WAIT FOR IT AND THEN THE AND LA
NIGHT.
THE BULLS LED BY 13 AND
PELICANS LED BY SEVEN,  AND
HERNANOGOMEZ, SHORT AND
REBOUND, ARC.
HE FINDS WHITE.
ANOTHER WIDE OPEN THREE BUT
THAT ONE WON'T GO DOWN.
13 OF 20.
INGRAM, HIS SPOT.
>>Stacey: DRIBBLES RIGHT TO A
SPOT ON THE FLOOR.
>>Adam: THE MOST IMPROVED
PLAYER AND A FIRST TIME ALL-
STAR LAST YEAR.
LaVINE AGAIN.
>>Stacey: OH, A
THE THIRD QUARTER FOR THE BULLS
ON FRIDAY REALLY DOOMED US.
LITTLE
BARRETT.
NO GOOD.
>> Stacey: HE PUSHED THE BALL.
>> Adam: THREE POSSESSION GAME.
ZACH LAVINE ALL TH TWO REMAININ
THEY WILL USE ONE HERE.
ZACH LAVINE WITH 24 POINTS,
FIVE REBOUNDS, SEVEN ASSISTS.
HE'S BEEN QUIET UNTIL THIS JAM.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK AFTER
THIS BREA
>> Adam: THEY HAVE A I COMING
INTO DO ENDORSEMENTS.
THAT WAS A BIG TIME STOP.
>> Stacey: OKAY.
>> Adam: AND BIG TIME, ZACH
LAVINE.
THAT WAS AN  ANGRY DUNK.  THAT
OFF THAT'S HAZACK THE MAKE HIS
MOVE BACK DOOR.
HE IS SMART AND SEES THAT MOVE
BY JOSH TO GET IN HIS CUT AND
TAKE, IT LOOKS
LIKE HE GOT INTO A FIGHT WITH A
POSSUM.
DRAW FOUL.
THAT WILL GO AGAINST THE
PISTONS.RIGHT HIP
INJURY FOR MOST OF THE SEASON.
THIS IS THE SHOT, LAVINE'S GOT
THE REBOUND.
FIRST OPPORTUNITY FOR HAYES TO
FACE THIS RIVAL.
>> Stacey: WATCH YOUR HEADBUMPE
DOUMBOUYA.
FIRST FOUL ON THE PISTONS ON
>> Stacey: BY THE TIME STEWART
RECOGNIZES IT, HE SAYS NO,
THERE'S NO WAY IN THE WORLD.
NOPE, NOPE, CAN'T DO IT.
CA